welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking
[Applause]
down Invincible season 2 episode 1 is
now out and throughout this video we're
going to be going through the Easter
eggs comic book differences and our
thoughts on the show I've just finished
up a major readr of the original work
and I really want to break down this
series to not only talk about how
references the comics but also some of
the differences they added in to change
things up we also interviewed Co Sher
executive producer and writer of this
first episode Simon rasop in it we
talked about the new season and answered
the questions that you really want to
know but I've always just wondered this
so JK Simmons he played Jay Jonah
Jameson now omn man looks like J Jonah
Jameson was there ever a point where you
were like we'll have to get him to to
play omn
Man exclusive exclusive exclusive the
question you want to know answered now
episode one has a bit of a misdirect
early on as it actually picks up in an
alternate universe this is one in which
Mark decided to join with his dad and
this world actually showed up early on
in the comics debuting in issue 16 that
was alongside angstrom Levy and it
started off with Mark putting a message
out of Time Square telling the citizens
that if they resisted then they were
going to die from here we could have
cross to a version of Levy running to a
box which was actually the secret
entrance to the resistance Hideout down
here we had Rob and also the immortal
who was beheaded just like how he is in
this opening fight this itself calls
back to when omn man first killed the
Guardians as he cut off the immortal's
head in an attempt to kill him compared
to the comics the show's way more
expanded with us meeting several of the
multiversal characters and seeing the
damage that marks caused in this Source
material all there really was was the
big screen and shock looks of Despair on
the people's faces opening with the
immortal getting killed this instantly
lets you know how dangerous these two
are the immortal has normally being one
who stood as the final stand and he of
course also rushed out of face omn man
when the truth was revealed going down
like this it's left Earth pretty
defenseless and we hear as Mark tries to
reassure Earth that joining them's the
right thing to do more you resist the
worse this gets your new Vite rulers are
on the way and it's time to join us in
welcoming them the sort of riffs on the
Time Square message of bit in which he
tells them that just because they're in
control it doesn't mean it's a bad thing
as he says on the giant screen being
part of the Empire comes with its
benefits and the comics actually argue
pretty well at joining them could be a
positive due to their scientific
discoveries they've pretty much wiped
out all kinds of diseases and they're
able to protect the planet from
invasions and ensure no one ever goes
hungry you can actually see why mark
would have sided with his dad and the
temptation to resist this shows how
strong arar actually is now as they say
they'd bring peace to Earth for
thousands of years and only upon
depleting Earth of its entire resources
would we all be left to die yay kind of
reminds me of that guy who spoils every
movie and show but you know subscribing
to him it's actually the right thing to
do you son of a [__] now they're
obviously completely oppressive people
that would use humanity and stomp us out
and thus the resistance is started to
mount up against them these broadcasts
are something that we've seen in the
series before with omn man delivering a
message worldwide during episode 3 the
citizens are terrified and that takes us
to Levy or rather a version of him that
we see moving throughout the streets he
wears a HUD to cover himself and this is
similar to what we see some of the
civilians wearing during the comic
broadcast going into the secret entrance
which is located in a bus instead we see
far more of a hive of humanity than what
we got in the comics robot is also in
his original form too as in this world
he didn't get to change whereas in the
other he did knowing the comics this
happened much later on than when it was
positioned in the first season with him
not being copied into a clone until
issue 35 Mark for his dad during issue
12 so he can see how much they've
changed things up I think that in this
Multiverse they may have killed the MERS
who then couldn't help the transfer and
NY got stuck like this the MERS not
being here explains why ly doesn't
recruit them so I'm kind of joining the
Dots here and trying to figure it out
now as we learn Rex blood was killed too
and he's turned into her nightmare
timeline version this is a completely
new addition for the story and they also
tease up Mock and eve were an item if
you read The Source material then you'll
know certain things are Hing at and it's
awesome to see these different
alterations I kind of view the comics as
its own Multiverse thing too and I love
seeing the changes and surprises that
they bring feels way more brutal with
how it plays out here and what Mark does
to Eve is so [__] up and I was
thinking she's sort of like almost a
metaphor for what humanity is going
through like she gets an next snaap
she's paralyzed but Mark's going to care
for her and that's kind of what I was
thinking Humanity was like you know
we're very much going to be held in
place by this V ultramite Invasion we're
going to get cared for because they've
got all the their Sciences but also
there's this horror that's kind of
hanging over it and I just love that
moment seeing the tear almost run down
her face and obviously you guys added
that in um was scripting that out did it
was it just an aha moment of we figured
a way to kind of transform this into one
big gut punch because that's what it
feels like it's just so messed up seeing
it happen oh good I'm glad it I'm glad
it affected you that way because that
was the intention yeah it was to show
you what what Vite occupation would be
like you know and for Eve it's it's
basically it's I love that metaphor that
you brought up that's basically what it
is is that you know we'll be a lie but
really are you going to call it living
you know with the Vite Empire's knee on
your back and also they're not just
going to Keep Us Alive to Keep Us Alive
they're going to Keep Us Alive to draw
out the resources of our planet to use
it as a staging base to take over other
planets like yeah we'll be alive but
like nobody wants to live like that you
know neither does Eve in that scene so
that's a way to take something take a
really big idea and make it very
personal and show it on screen happening
in front of your face uh rather than
having to do like you know montages of
the vites arriving with their ships and
stuff like this we try to make it
personal yeah I think that the way
you've used the Multiverse as well to
just show kind of both sides on it to
show what an invasion actually looks
like and then it kind of adds more
weight to why Mark had to stop his from
in initiating it but so messed up is omn
man and says huh so that's what you were
practicing on those protesters last week
at this point Ley speaks up with
Sterling K Brown delivering a chilling
monologue all omn man cares about though
is getting his Lune and murdering on
mass the rest of the resistance you can
just see the terror on their face and
it's such a chilling way to open up the
season the levu gets grabbed by the
prime vision of himself who in both
opens up a portal and pulls himself
through what they've done with the show
is kind of condense several of his
moments across the issue so they can
tell a major part of his Arc during one
episode for example in the comics he'd
have things started throughout and would
rescue the MERS during issue 17 then
issue 22 he'd be working with the
machine with issue 24 being where they
combined all their brains what you get
is a way more streamlined story and also
his prime version explaining what's
going on basically the way Ley works is
that there's a version of them that can
open up portals and this allows to
travel across the Multiverse the second
season it takes a big focus on the
Multiverse with the introduction of
angstrom Levy now multiverses are
obviously a big thing in the comic book
industry right now and I was wondering
you know coming into this if there was
anything that you guys thought how are
we going to differentiate this and and
make it really pop sure yeah I mean well
one of the big things obviously you know
Invincible is based off the comic book
series uh which just celebrated his 20th
anniversary so you know Robert did this
m Multiverse thing in this Comics 15
years ago you know at least uh so you
know we're not we're not hopping on the
bandwagon we're just catching up to
where it happens in our source material
um so I I think our approach to is like
we
never uh we're not approaching it to
make a Multiverse story no one's like
you know it's not like you we've had
multiple iterations of Batman or
multiple iterations of Spider-Man or the
flash those don't exist for invincible
so it's like we don't have that
Nostalgia thing of like oh let's let's
see all the let's see Michael Keon again
that's amazing you know or let's see all
the different Batmans together all the
different Ninja Turtles together um so
that was never Our intention we were
never doing this as a response to any of
those other movies which by the way are
great and I love them all're and they're
awesome uh ours is a little more
character-based you know we have we're
we're actually more telling the story of
angstrom Levy and he happens to have
this power this is his background that
he can travel through Dimensions so we
started with a character first and in
the comic books and just focused on that
rather than trying to be like okay this
is our Multiverse version it's not it's
not that we're doing a character story
and just the Multiverse happens to you
know be a part of it I guess definitely
we also get this super cold line but you
should have died at
Birth this plays into the whole Vite
philosophy of survival of the fittest
the closest big example I can think of
is America Chavez though Levy debuted
almost 10 years earlier unlike America
he stays in the same spot across all
realities though whereas she's able to
jump about from place to place so for
him say he'd be sat in his living room
and then jump through a portal he'd
still end up in his living room in an
alternate reality if there was something
else there then he'd hit whatever that
is so he needs all the knowledge from
the other angstroms to navigate the
Multiverse this is also how when the
MERS escape the prison they see a Dead
version of the God because they're in
the position the prison was just in an
alternate universe so basically angstrom
could walk into the prison pull them out
and walk to another reality walk outside
the limits of the ground and then walk
back to be outside now in the main
timeline we cut to Mark at the side of
the last place that he saw his father at
broken and beaten The Blood Still
Remains and this was a really defining
location for him in so many ways it's
also the place we started at at the
beginning of episode 4 and we have the
site where he grew closer and further
apart from his father to the sound of
Karma Police we hear Tom York singing
over the top of Mark going about his
superhero life it's clear he just going
through the motions though and doing it
for the sake of doing it rather than
finding it fun and exciting like he used
to another the term Karma Police was
coed by the band when they said they'd
call the Karma Police if someone did
something bad what it really meant
though is dealing with feelings of
stress and having people look at you in
a negative way that's something Mark has
to deal with and obviously people no
longer trust superheroes which we kind
of see the reactions of as he flies past
a giant screen I think this is the same
place where Mark broadcasts from in the
alternate Dimension and we can even see
the same woman from that intro scene
standing with the crowd any kid who's
watch their parents go through a divorce
will instantly be able to relate to this
and he can just feel the isolation and
almost guilt seeping through the screen
as Mark moves through the city at this
point we see Mark busting up the
elephant who as I'm sure you can guess
is a super villain that's based on the
Rhino this fight actually pulls directly
from the comics with a seeing a play out
at the midpoint of issue eight it's
clear Mark is just attached from
everything though and he doesn't really
stop to chat to the people he's helping
and instead just as his job moves on
this is the case with the car chase
ambulance flight and also that bank
robbery the music and tones a far cry
from The Rock and pop songs we got in
the original series with us letting us
know that the lien Mark's life has gone
along with his dad at the bank we see
two returning characters who come in the
form of Mag maniac and tether Tyrant
these two are from Botha comic and show
with them appearing during the Titan
takeover episode showing up on pages 455
in the Omnibus tether Tyrant was someone
that no one knew what he really did now
though things are bad with Mark we still
see that there's some positivity in the
world Earth is starting to rebuild and
Debbie's going back to work as a real
estate agent still though there will
always be these reminders most notably
the house across the street where Donald
and his surveillance team were located
caught by omn man he ended up
self-destructing and leaving a crater
which serves as a bit of reminder out in
the desert we see the prison in which
the MERS are kept at the guns are primed
on the surface and during their season
one Escape one of them was killed trying
to get out and the God here always kind
of reminded me of Captain America and
during season one MOA broke his arm this
was then up in a cast during the finale
which the MERS also talk about here you
should count yourself lucky there Pete
you could have torn your arm off now the
portal appear here pulling them out the
cells which is exactly what happens
during the source material in this scene
we also cut to a prisoner and this is
actually duplicates brother who's known
as multia multipul is going to play a
major part down the line and it was so
cool seeing a tease to him here now in
the alternate Dimension we pretty much
get a scene that's pulled right out of
the comics in which he takes them
through a timeline in which the prison
was wiped out we catch the Iguana
showing how the realities are similar
but that there's also these key
differences here now why he needs a
morees is because of their abilities to
move Minds which we saw them
demonstrating with robot the source of
the fact he can reach in and get
untapped knowledge that only exists in
certain realities now back to traversing
the Multiverse in the comics he had to
Mark locations with a red X and this
would give him an idea of where to
travel still though there was always
going to be the risk and thus he didn't
jump as far as he felt like he should be
doing anyway from here we C to Reginal
Val Johnson High School and and I know I
do this Easter egg almost every video
but it's a new season so why not now
Reginal Val Johnson High School is named
after the actor who played BN Winslow
during Family Matters this character
then inspired principal Winslow's design
who Reginal Val Johnson now provides the
voice of also made me wonder about J
Jonah Jameson cuz I know there's lots of
things going on with JK Simmons but I've
always just wondered this so J JK
Simmons he played Jay Jonah Jameson now
omn man looks like J Jonah Jameson was
there ever a point where you like we'll
have to get him to to play omn man you
know what the one of the reasons that we
looked at him early on and want wanted
him for the role was I I saw him in
Whiplash yeah and he scared the [__] out
of me in Whiplash and but also starts
the movie being like kind of this nice
guy and he's able to flip between being
a normal person like a normal dad and
the most terrifying person ever on film
uh and that is omim man we knew omn man
was going to have to make that change he
was going to start off being this great
dad but also have these enormously Dark
Places he would go to in these really
terrifying moments you know I always
think of vites as being like a great
white shark like you're in the water and
there's great white shark swimming
around and if it chooses to kill you
that that's just what's going to happen
so it's this terrifying moment of just
not knowing what he's going to do and
seeing JK and
Whiplash uh I was like we need to look
at him like this is this is the kind of
the change the dichotomy that we need
for this character so yeah so that was
one of the reasons we uh we went with
Jake a and looked at him early of I mean
he's an incredible actor 100 times over
looks Jonah Jameson looks like omn man
yeah yeah I have to get this right yeah
I mean like they yeah there's a yeah
they kind of look the same I guess but
honestly that's honestly that's not cast
him I wish it was we should just cast
every character who just looks like the
actor who looks the most like the the
character yeah now inside we see his tog
hugs it out with Mark and you might
remember him from the first season as
being someone who hit him this happened
in the exact same spot but we can see
Todd's letting up here because of what's
happened with Mark's dad now the cover
story for Allan being gone is that he
was killed in the house explosion
whereas in the comics they put it down
to a car crash that house didn't
actually appear in the comics and I
really enjoyed this Improvement to kind
of tie the two events together now we
could at the Burger Mar where Mark used
to work and we see is he's meeting up
with Cecil this is a slight changer from
the comics is in though Cecil met him in
his room and then Mark went out to
Burger Mar with William and a buddy at
this point his old manager confronted
him whereas that was a scene that they
used in season 1 and all Mark want to do
is go back to saving people and this is
to make up of what happened during that
massive fight Cecil says that he needs
to focus on his grades though and that
that will be the best way to get his
head straight all Mark wants to prove
though is that he's not his dad which is
a theme that reappears throughout the
rest of the episode a Cil as always has
an ulterior motive and the reason he
doesn't trust Mark is because he's half
builtrite he understands the Loyalty
that one would have with a farther and
therefore wants to keep him on a short
leash so he doesn't cause any problems
as we saw in the intro the pair work
working together would destroy the
planet and even things like helping the
Guardians is something that he's not
deemed fit for now they take him in a
way different Arc to the comics as in
those he didn't really have the
complexity that they have here even in
issue 14 he was back out battling the
flax and Empire with the Guardians all
at his side this feels way more
developed than what it was in The Source
material and I love the extra character
depth that they added here now the
villain they're fighting is known as the
Giant and he's ripped right out of the
pages of the comics he says and I want
to be president of America and an
astronaut which is something that he
also says during his comic appearances
now it's a pretty infantile thing to say
and that's because a Giant's actually an
8-year-old boy falling through a portal
he was Bewitched by a wizard who wanted
to use him as a way to Smite his enemies
however he didn't count on kids being so
rebellious unless he ended up going on a
rampage and we get to see the Guardians
busting him up and they sort of act like
an Avengers standing robot now has a
metal suit and heads of display like
Iron Man and we see Monster Girls
sliding down a building just like how
Hulk does you also see is the former
struggles with the fear of battle as in
the past he's controlled things through
a neural link from here we cut of the
darks which is also where Levy was based
at in the comics this is the place he
took the doppelgangers to after pulling
them out the portals but they just
condens his stuff here to have it with
the Moret he promises them a world and
among these we can see one that looks
like Midnight City this was based on
Batman the Animated Series and judging
by the Red Sky I think it's the same all
this other worldly knowledge is suan
angstrom once but in the end when he's
scorned by Invincible his goals start to
change now he ends up showing them all
as the family of levies which is similar
to the panel in the comics in which he
showed both his doppelgangers and them
the same thing the machine explanation
actually happens later on in issue 20 so
that kind of gives you an idea of how
these stories were paced out C Debbie
who we see coming across olra in her
home and you might remember that she was
going out with red Rush red Rush was of
course killed by Nolan and the pair are
kind of in the exact same predicament
Debbie talks about how she was in Italy
last year which was a vacation we saw
during season 1 she's still not used to
him being out her life and Olga
understands this more than anyone else
Debbie still can't get over being
classed as a pet though which was one of
the coldest lines in the entire show I
do love your mother but she's more like
a a pet to me oh Nowa gives her a card
that will allow to deal with what she's
dealing with mentally and from here we
could have the Guardians of the globe
base where they're getting berated for
how they handle the giant this moment is
brand new for the show and it reminded
me a lot of General Ross's talk during
Civil War in that he showed the
destruction The Avengers had rought
which in itself had harmed innocent
lives that's very much the case with
what we see here and we can catch the
dead left in the destruction choking it
up to a failure of leadership this all
rests at Rudy's feet The Immortal is now
the one who's been put in charge and as
we know he led the Guardians before Rex
blod goes off on him and he acts like a
dick but hey honestly you shouldn't
treat the guy too harshly in the comics
we got a secret origin for him in which
it talking about how he came from a poor
family man was picked up and then
experimented on which is how he was able
to then get his powers going back to see
his parents he watched as they profited
off of him and were happy with him gone
which was a devastating reveal the comic
even said next time he's acting like a
jerk have a little compassion and hey
Rex it's it's okay mate you be a dick
now bulletproof is also brought in two
who comes from the comics little bit of
trivia but in the source material Mark
was actually offered his costume when he
was first starting out art had it just
lying around and it was only when Mark
asked for a custom one that it got
changed up now if you're looking for
some new clothes yourself then
definitely check out our merch store
located just below the video yes we're
spamming you with ads we just launched
the first in our Classic Movies
breakdown versus design which which is
inspired by two James Cameron Classics
and already Scot it as well now we also
got Loki and ahoka designs on there too
as well as a theory time one and a lot
more it all helps videos like this get
made and huge thank you to everyone
who's bought one shabow now we also see
his Rudy and monster get a little closer
and she was the person that made him
want to duplicate his brain now speaking
of getting closer we see even Mark
meeting up at school with a former
coming to visit him to see how he is
currently she's out living in the woods
whereas in the she' moved all the way
out to Africa Mark just feels distant
though and like he can't connect with
his dad which has obviously left a
massive hole in his life Mark says that
when he was a kid he wanted to be just
like him but now he's moving in the
exact opposite direction obviously Cecil
doesn't know whether he can be trusted
or not and we cut to him watching
surveillance footage of the MERS this is
ripped right out of the end of issue 21
and Donald's been added in to give his
character more to do he was kind of kept
out the way during these early stories
with him becoming way more important
later down the line now Mark begs him to
go back in the field and this leads to
Cil finally putting his trust in him
this takes us to a scene that was ripped
right out of issue 24 with pretty much
all the moments here ripping off of that
it's such an amazing battle scene in The
Source material and watching it come to
live made for a big final fight scene
it's kind of got a basis in horror with
the whole mind transfer seeming
agonizing and this all plays out as
angstrom gets smarter in the end he
comes out looking like a monster and
this is of course down to the experiment
getting interrupted Mar arrives and he
finally seems happy once the MERS
challenge him to a fight I do kind of
feel bad Fang strumming away because his
heart was in the right place and all he
wanted to do was use the Multiverse to
help people there'll be realities out
there that can help cure disease and
make a Utopia with all a combined
knowledge no one man should have all
that power though and thus he unleashes
the other MERS that he's been working
with this bit is pulled right out of the
comics but they added in a bit about how
they thought they'd been working alone
MOA is all about being the superior one
and even among the Clones they argue
about who the better one is now just
like the comics angstrom ends up taking
the helmet off when he realizes the MERS
are going to kill mock the last thing he
want is a legacy built-in blood and in
both this this causes the machine to
explode amongst the wreckage we see all
the dead MERS which is just like how
it's presented in the source of material
the Guardians sent you up just like how
they did in that but they add a bit with
a blood of Mark's hand that makes them
feel like a monster I don't think it's
any coincidence that we started this
episode with him staring at blood and it
seems like no matter what he does it's
always going to be shed all his actions
have led to even more destruction and
death and you can tell that Mark just
feels like he's failed all he ever
wanted to do was hell people and in many
ways he sort of Echoes Levy the road to
hell is paved with good intentions and
it's something that both him and levie
are going to have to deal with wanting
to go back home we see how he and his
mother are now in a divided home but but
some good news has come for him in the
mail both he and Amber have been
accepted at Upstate University and it
feels like a win in what's been a pretty
D entry still though Mark hasn't won the
trust of everyone and we see as the
immortal confronts him outside his home
it brings things full circle from that
opening scene in which an alternate Mark
ended up helping to kill him this scene
itself is actually pulled directly from
issue 14 with the dialogue in meeting
place being exactly the same it's kind
of a depressing way to close it out with
the comics then Mark to go on to meet
cile who had the convo about his dad
dramatically though I think this works
way better as the impact of that was cut
short by that being the next thing yeah
though you really feel for Mark and to
make matters worse MOA and angstrom have
survived we see a half more M and this
is a really good connection as it looks
exactly like how it does in this Source
material Ley also comes out looking
worse for where with his giant brain now
protruding out his head grabbing it and
screaming like how he did in the comics
it's it's at this point he swears
Vengeance on Mark having memories from
across the Multiverse has meant in every
reality that Mark and his dad have
killed Millions these losses and
memories are now part of Levy and he
swears Revenge which sets up a Big Arc
we finally get that title reveal and it
feels like the perfect way to close out
the entry as dropping it here add so
much more impact we end with m also
calling him a jerk as levie leavy and
it's just like the comics which I can't
wait for you guys to see what happens
down the line now this I also asked
whether there were any crossovers that
we could be getting with some other
Amazon superheroes and just speaking of
the Multiverse in general now this is a
I don't need you I don't think you'll
confirm this if it's happening but
obviously you worked on the boys
presents diabolical as well that's under
the Amazon Prime video umbrella I know
Invincible the comics have a lot of
crossovers with other comic book
universes um but is there any way that
you would perhaps tie in you know those
two properties with one thing Amazon I
mean that would be great I mean I know I
think I'm the only person who's worked
on both the boys and Invincible uh
together um I mean that would be
wonderful we don't have anything planned
or anything we can announce right now I
think Robert's talked about it too I
know Evan and Seth have brought it up a
bunch of times so it would be great we
here's the thing we would only do it if
it made sense like we don't want to do
it as a stunt I I don't want to do it as
a stunt you know could we do a CR could
you see omn man and like homelander face
off sure but like was that where would
that fit in either the boys or in
invincible and make sense and make
narrative sense we don't want to make it
feel like oh it's a stunt to just get
you guys to watch it I mean besides
people do that there's already a great
someone did a great animation of
homelander versus omn Man online on
YouTube I think it's amazing and
hilarious and great I'm like oh someone
already did it better than we would do
it so uh so that's the thing I don't
want to sacrifice The Narrative and the
emotion of either show to make a
crossover where it doesn't make sense so
if if some something came up that made
that felt real and felt good I'm sure we
could we would have a conversation talk
about it uh that hasn't happened yet no
I think the new Mortal Kombat game as
well has got them both in as a bonus
character it does yeah yeah and of
course but that's its own universe
that's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no
that's that looks really cool so yeah
lots of look forward to and I really
enjoyed this first entry I know I
probably obsess over issue numbers and
stuff and blah blah blah but look mate
I'm a nerd I always love how they
combine certain story lines take them in
New Directions though and generally just
change the flow and where the series is
going they added so much depth here and
made Mark a way more layered character
than what I was expecting cuz the the
comics are kind of brushed over it here
it's far more introspective and it
perfectly deals with the depression that
you often have when a parents no longer
in your life I know you guys can apply
this to a lot of things as well and it
just adds an extra layer relatability in
a show that's dealing with superhumans
really good first episode filled with
that action emotion and in the end some
nice twists and turns also just just had
like the the sheer [__] hell moments
that invincibles known for huh so that's
what you were practicing on those
protesters last week and yeah did I
enjoy that not really um but I was
entertained which might make me a sicko
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts and we will be back next week
with even more bits from our interview
with Simon make sure you stay subscribed
and also let me know your thoughts Below
on what you want to see in the season
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the member as a
Channel of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button get early
access to videos every week and it goes
such a long way to helping us out now if
you want something else to watch we've
also got a video on screen right now
we're pumping out so many at the moment
so yeah please head over there after
this got cover and Loki cover and gen VY
they're all wrapping up and yeah
hopefully I'll see you guys over at one
of those videos out the way huge thank
you for clicking this I've been poor
I'll see you next time take care peace